as many of you know we were on vacation
last week I'll have lots of stories for
you from the vacation on the bonus show
today some some really good ones that I
think you'll like I did everything I
could to disconnect from the work things
during to disconnect from work basically
during the break one of the things I
came back to were more than a dozen
bogus copyright claims against our
YouTube channel from huge corporate
legacy media outlets now some of you may
remember that we dealt with this during
the presidential debates we would do
live commentary of a debate the debate
may be it was on CNN and CNN would shut
it down they would file a copyright
claim and then it was sort of like a
debate is it fair use is it not okay
that's not what I came back to what I
came back to are straight-up bogus
copyright claims when we've not used any
content from the claimant it's always a
huge corporate media outlet and YouTube
is straight-up ignoring us which I'm
going to get to in a moment this is how
they will destroy independent media take
a look at this this is my inbox this is
partial this is about a dozen of them
there are more on videos ranging from
House Intelligence Committee hearings
House Judiciary hit hearings simply
house video of the house debating
impeachment for 12 hours we spent all
day on multiple days producing these
streams using public domain video from
the House of Representatives not copy
written video and then in comes
corporate media and just claims the
video here's one specifically live Trump
impeachment hearing number five Gordon
Sunland received a third party claim
from Associated Press UK another example
from Univision and there were many from
Univision this was for Trump impeachment
hearing day three when it was Alexandrov
Inman and Jennifer Williams this one
from Univision I won't put them all up
on the screen I think you get the idea
NBC Univision Associated Press CNN on
and on and on since the hearings have
started I would estimate that we've
received 22 21
five bogus completely bogus copyright
claims from legacy corporate media
outlets whose content we have not used I
have been told by people in my audience
that attorney Leonard French also
received a bunch from Univision and that
he's taking legal action I have reached
out to Leonard and were scheduled to
speak at the end of this week or early
next now let's think through the next
step okay because YouTube does have a
process for disputing these claims the
way it's supposed to work is once you
say no I don't agree with this claim I'm
going to dispute it all of the money
that's earned from that point forward is
held in escrow and once the claim is
adjudicated the money money is given to
whoever has the rights to the video but
it's not so simple because number one
the escrow period only starts when I
filed the dispute we were away all of
last week these are videos still getting
numerous views we're a full week goes by
before I got home and filed the dispute
that money's gone no matter what happens
number two YouTube is not really
adjudicating the dispute when I file a
dispute CNN or Univision or whoever gets
30 days to say you know what David was
right or yeah we don't think David was
right and after that I don't know that
there is any further recourse that I
have if they say we're keeping the
dispute going they can simply say
David's wrong and they keep the money
now many of you might be wondering but
David here your channel has almost
800,000 subscribers you're like in the
top half of 1% of YouTube you must have
a contact at YouTube right I do I have a
YouTube rep who I've been emailing for
months about this the YouTube rep
typically responds with a conversation
with a combination of I'm away Auto
responses saying I'm looking into this
and I'll follow up and of course there's
no follow up or simply ignoring my
emails or saying you are actually going
to be getting a new YouTube rep but then
I never am put in touch with the new
YouTube rep the system is broken the
system is crushing us
merely by making me have to deal with
this this is a common tactic when you
a law firm representing a large
corporation and their what they want to
go after a small business or an
individual one of the ways that they gum
up the system is sending endless
discovery requests requests for
documents filing all sorts of different
motions that the small business or the
individual either become overwhelmed
with by having to fight or can't afford
the legal fees required in order to do
it so that they are completely taken out
of actually running their business and
that is the equivalent of what is going
on here and this is going to get worse
in 2020 with more and more political
coverage across corporate media and I
don't know what we can do certainly the
solution is to be less reliant on
YouTube revenue at all and that's fine
which is why I say you know get a
membership it's cheap I won't spend a
lot of time on it david pakman.com slash
membership just sign up take the big
discount we have through the end of the
year last 2019 if you want throw us a
dollar or two a month on patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show but
this is bigger than just moving support
from YouTube ad revenue to individual
support something needs to be done here
right we don't seem to be able to fight
this in any serious way because the
system is skewed towards huge corporate
media outlets often algorithmically
filing claims which then puts the onus
on me to go and fight them instead of
creating content so I'm going to speak
to Leonard French about this and the
next week or end of this week early next
hopefully folks will continue to just
say screw YouTube I'm going to support
you directly through membership and
patreon and I'll update you when I have
more information really ugly stuff
that's going on